every little thing you think that's me
every little thing is imagine me every
little thing that's just feeding your
greenido I bet that you'll find out
hey everybody just a quick note before
we get started here this is a little
bonus episode when we were in Portland
Oregon last week we had the opportunity
to stop by pri they have a live radio
show once a month they do it in front of
a studio audience which was really cool
it's a Public Radio International Vee
the show is called Live Wire and what
you're about to hear is our segment that
we had on there they had us play a
little game where they brought some
stuff up and and we had to convince them
to either get rid of the thing or hold
onto the thing but we also gave some
background on our story had a good
conversation with all the folks over
there at livewire before you jump in
real quick today is the day today is the
day we are announcing the second leg of
the LES is now tour we're coming to a
city near you we're in the middle of
this tour right now and we just
announced the the second leg so you can
find all these cities and dates over at
les is now calm we're headed to Toronto
Ottawa Montreal Vancouver Calgary
Edmonton Philadelphia we got a couple
stops in New York Manhattan and Brooklyn
and in Salt Lake City Denver Phoenix
Austin Dallas Houston Nashville
Washington DC atlanta Tampa Detroit and
Milwaukee that's the entire second leg
of the lessons now tour but we still
have some cities left in the the first
leg of the tour as well we'll be in
Grand Rapids Chicago Madison Minneapolis
San Diego Los Angeles that one's about
to sell out but you can still get
tickets
San Francisco Indianapolis Cincinnati
Columbus and Cleveland a lot of these
events we've already had have sold out
many of these wills so you may want to
grab your tickets sooner than later we
can't be responsible if you don't get
the tickets in time that's really up to
you but I know if you're anything like
Ryan you might want to wait until the
last day I just let you know it the last
day might be might be too late but we're
really looking forward to seeing you on
the road we've been having a blast at
these events the whole team is their
podcast Sean Jess who helps out with our
our social media in fact we just sang
happy birthday to podcast Sean
in last time we were in Portland Oregon
and had a blast doing that well we'll
eventually get that podcast out as well
but looking forward to seeing you on the
road until then enjoy this bonus edition
of the minimus podcast this is us on
livewire on Public Radio International
our first guests have taken cutting the
craft to an entirely different level
through their podcast and books and blog
Joshua fields Milburn and Ryan McKee
Dimas better known as the minimalists
have preached the gospel of cluttering
to millions and they're not just talking
about physical stuff they've also they
also talk about the emotional junk that
so many of us are carrying around and
it's knowledge that's hard-won from
their own lives as we're about to learn
please welcome the minimalist livewire
[Music]
hugging is such a big part of what the
minimalists do I'm learning but they're
free and transferable Joshua and Ryan
welcome to live wire anything for
evidence all right does the whole
interview going to be in stereo yeah
you guys spend a lot of time again it
and we even finish each other's with the
sandwiches you guys might want to
download some podcast in the car and
listen to those or something to pass the
time cuz you're your melding into the
same person with all those hours on the
road together and we've known each other
since we were fat little fifth graders
and it was like the lonely lunch table
we met on this place in Ohio
yeah in Ohio and born and raised rude in
Montana now but yeah we
yes and sure there's one Montana Hannah
the Ohio of the West
I think anybody says that thank you sure
Joshua let's start with you because am i
understanding that this whole minimalist
thing that you two are involved and kind
of got started with you what did your
life look like back in around 2011 kind
of before things started to change for
you yeah so for me I'm 35 now but when I
was say 27 28 I was I'm sort of living
the American dream it was after actually
growing up poor in Dayton Ohio I was
raised by an alcoholic single mother we
were on food stamps and government
assistance and I thought the reason we
were so unhappy is because we didn't
have a lot of money right and so when I
turned 18 I went out and got a corporate
job and I spent the next decade climbing
the corporate ladder and really by age
20 you 728 I had achieved everything I
ever wanted
that six-figure salary a V the luxury
car the closets full of designer clothes
the big suburban house with more toilets
than people I relate all the stuff I
need that but that's a medical thing I'm
getting to that later
but also living in the American dream
right but but then my mom died and my
marriage ended both in the same month
and and your how old at this point of
twenty it was 2009 October 2009 and
those two events forced me to sort of
look around and start a question when it
become my life's focus what I realized
as I was so focused on so-called success
and achievement and especially on the
accumulation of stuff and I realized
that yeah I might have been living the
American dream but it wasn't my dream
and it sort of for me it took everything
getting everything I thought I wanted to
realize that maybe everything I ever
wanted wasn't actually what I wanted at
all and that's really when I discovered
this thing called minimalism and did you
basically just like start looking at
blogs or go online I mean how does
minimalism enter your consciousness in
Dayton Ohio Twitter no seriously I I
call it either but so this is on
November 2009 I didn't do the whole
social media thing but I signed up for
Twitter and Facebook and MySpace all in
the same day Wow
and gone Friendster
I'm still trying yeah but no I'm so I
told this video of a guy named Colin
right he was this 24-year old
entrepreneur and everything he owns his
backpack and I thought that was kind of
cool but it was in really extreme to me
but then I discovered there are other
minimalist there were people like Leo
and Eva boob Alta they have six kids and
so they're like minimus except with the
whole kid thing
yeah and they were most everywhere in
between I realized if I wanted to
simplify my life I'd have to find out a
while and recipe was so I sort of
squeezed ingredients from each of these
different minimalist recipes and created
my own intentional life based on on what
I was seeing in these other people and
so then Ryan how did you start to notice
that something was different with your
old pal Joshua well we were working at
the same corporation side-by-side
climbing the corporate ladder together
throughout our 20s and I remember on
when he split up with his with his wife
I was helping him move into his new
place and there was like this really
awesome like wall mount that was already
there for a TV and this was like in the
corporate world like we were always
comparing like you know the who had the
latest TV technology how big was the TV
how many TVs that we have I mean it was
like sore throats and yeah but I
remember seeing that I want to do what
kind of TV are we gonna get and he was
like you know yeah I don't know and
welcome I don't know if I am taking the
TV and I was like why okay like yeah
maybe a couple months go by no TVs no
and I didn't really question him on that
I just you know accepted the fact that
he wasn't going to get a TV and then I
remembered him doing things like um so
our boss he basically was always calling
us for sales numbers and especially
during the holiday season I mean we
worked in retail that was like
season on the air so who said Christmas
Eve josh is out with his partner at the
time and he was telling me the story
about how our boss was calling him and
he's like you know you know our boss is
calling me I'm out to dinner was it with
you no my girlfriend and I kept ignoring
his call he kept calling me finally pick
it up and I'm like josh is like a man
but we can now deal with and he was a
worrier stores out how much have you
sold today on Christmas Eve Christmas is
some Charles Dickens pair I mean if I
stand and Josh Mikey
this is funny this is an unreasonable
expectation you're setting right now and
like that was sacrilegious in our in our
world so you know I started noticing
these little changes and I noticed Josh
being happier he was he was nicer he was
a little a little freer and eventually I
sat him down and I'm like dude why the
hell are you so happy what is going on
with you and I thought like maybe the
doctor give them some good drugs or
something and I was like you know I
wanted something real is it Prozac like
what are you on man and he was like no
it's not like that all he spent like 20
minutes telling me about this thing
called minimalism he talked about how he
spent the last several months of his
life just simplifying getting the
clutter out of the way and then it
started to make sense a little bit and
then he introduced me to the people that
he just talked about Colin and Leo and
there were a couple other folks and I
you know I was a pretty pretty a big
problem solving guy and when I noticed
like this community of happy people I
saw how was working for Josh I'm like
all right dude I want to do this I want
to be a minimalist now what do I do
that's I think that's the question a lot
of people probably have we're talking to
Ryan dick and we're talking to Ryan
Nicodemus and Joshua fields Millburn
also known as the minimalism what
more the first thing in the Ryan like
what did you get rid of first so I
didn't want to spend several months
simplifying my life like Josh had I mean
that was great for him that I needed
faster results so we came up with a
crazy idea called a packing party where
we decided to tack all my belongings as
if I were moving and then I would unpack
only the items I needed over the next
few weeks so Josh came over literally
helped me box up everything my clothes
my kitchen where my towels my TVs my
electronics my framed photographs and
paintings my toiletries I mean even my
furniture everything we literally
pretended like I was moving so my
friends would get like 12 minutes into
this experiment that'd be like we'll be
at the bar this is a good friend
actually went through the process yes
actually doing that took about nine
hours yeah get a couple piece of
deliveries sure and I probably drink
like just expected the whole thing but
you know it was crazy man I remember
like the first kind of revelation moment
I had and like Josh left and I've got
you know my my second living room filled
with all these boxes and you know this
fact halfway to my to open ceiling I'm
looking at it like wow here is here are
all these things I brought into my life
over the last decade I'm just sitting
here in this room so that was kind of
like my first kind of you know it's a
real moment I guess and then I spent the
next 21 days unpacking only the atoms I
needed my my toothbrush you know bettan
bedsheets some clothes for work some
kitchen like you could have left the
toothbrush out
no matter how minimal you are even just
for the sake of the people who love you
yeah yeah I don't think we're minimizing
away from one IP you know for me for me
I really I really have to do something
drastic to charge my state gotcha
and the more I could change my state and
more it will actually have an impact on
my life so I went through this whole
process and after those three weeks I
had 80% of my stuff smell sitting in
those boxes like just sitting there on
access and you know I looked at those
well I can even I look at this box and I
can't even remember what was in half of
them and I was thinking to myself like
this I'm pretty cool experiment like if
we share this you know with people like
maybe maybe they would get some value
out of it and Josh have some you know
cool insights and stories and I was like
maybe you know people will get value out
of out of our story so we did what any
to severe old dudes would do we started
the blog yes the first vlog in the
history of the Internet yes wait no it's
not that
wait we got sleepy let's take a very
quick break we have the minimalists here
we have Ryan Nicodemus and Joshua fields
Milberg this is live wire radio from PRI
we will be back in just a moment
welcome back to livewire radio for PRI
my name is Luke Burbank I'm here talking
to the minimalists our theme this week
is cut the crap which is something that
is kind of their specialty through their
podcast and blog and the documentary
film that that they made about really
trying to focus on the important things
in life if you have like a one or two
sentence description of what the
minimalist ethos is about Joshua what
would that be
minimalism is the thing that gets us
passing things so we can make room for
life's most important things which
actually aren't things at all what what
is the what's the science behind why
more stuff doesn't make us more happy or
did you the average American household
has more than 300 thousand items in it
three hundred thousand does that include
dust mite
and Instagram 300 thousand I think most
of us aren't hoarders right we're not
candidates for the TV show but we just
hold onto a lot of stuff but I think the
reason being is we want to like this
lifetime of collected memories and we
hold on to all of these things just in
case the three most dangerous words in
the English language and so I really
think it comes down to we we cause these
things because we feel like that's what
we're supposed to do or we're going to
need these things someday and some
non-existent hypothetical future that's
the first side the other side of a bit
more pernicious and it is we buy a bunch
of things with money we don't have to
impress people we don't like well when
you say it that way it doesn't seem like
such a great plan if I went in to Ryan
if I went in to your house what would I
see like what's in there what does a
minimalist house actually look like Luke
I wish I had like a really sexy answer
for you man you know you walked into my
home you would see I've got you know
couple paintings on the wall oh yeah
that's that's enough
I monitor and attire you know at the end
of the day like if you were to walk into
me and my partner's home like you
wouldn't jump up and say oh my god there
must be minimalists that live here you'd
probably be like maybe well inches are
pretty tidy and it's because you know
everything I own it serves a purpose or
adds value to my life it brings me joy
and at the end of the day everything
else I've gotten rid of and when you do
that there's these beautiful side
effects like you've got a nice tidy home
you consume less so you you have less
waste I'm able to you know move on a on
a dime like if I really had to pick up
and move everything it wouldn't take
that long for me to pack everything up
so you know I don't have to store quite
walls it's not like I don't believe in
couches or or I sleep on the floor and
there are some minimalist to do they get
a lot of value out of that up sleep on
the floor and you know there are people
who argue that there's not benefits of
that but you know I think that's a
beautiful thing about minimalism is
there isn't this one particular recipe
you have to follow it's more about just
making sure that the things you have in
your life that you're bringing those
things in deliberately and it really
just makes it easier for a simple life
now I don't want people to confuse a
simple life with an easy life because
I'll tell you man easy arms are simple
is not always necessarily easy well yeah
because I was I was watching the
documentary that you guys are a part of
I was listening to the podcast this week
you have books that are out you're on
this tour it seems like your life is
maybe more complicated now as
professional minimalist than it was when
you just working perfect
trying to sell cellphones to children
when you call yourself no minimalists
everything you do is steeped in irony
right right well are your lives I mean
because of the success of the blog and
all the projects you guys are raising
money to build a video studio now so you
can do more video projects I mean have
you been so successful that your lives
are not able to be as focused on the
stuff that you started outlining to
focus on
I think the difference now is my short
term actions aligned with my long term
values if you're the book to bear in
mind my motor cd20 is like I wouldn't
have been able to identify what my
values were let alone a lion lion my
daily actions with those values and so
now it's really about it's not totally
about being happy or in fact I think
being our chasing happiness was really
the problem for me I was constantly
chasing this thing called happiness but
now I'm living a more meaningful life
and the beautiful thing about that is
happiness is as a by-product event I
noticed that you're wearing a jacket
I think Joshua that you're also wearing
in the documentary is that right this
might be right like I think there are
extremely similar because you leaving
the house to go on this road trip with
Ryan and you're like oh I need a jacket
and I it looks very similar do you own
like one jacket and how did you decide
what the jacket was going to be there's
a lot of pressure
if you have one of
a certain kind of garment well I'm going
to get the consumption right I don't
think consumption is the problem I think
we all need some stuff I think the
problem is compulsory consumption so I
used to own twelve Brooks Brothers suits
I own seventy Brooks Brothers shirts you
got to work really freaking hard to wear
70 shirts in one month in two months
right and so now I mean I don't own a
whole lot of stuff but everything that I
own all of my belongings my clothes my
car my kitchen where my furniture it has
a function and/or brings me joy
somewhere it's artwork or music or
something like that and so the cool
thing about this is as my life changes
the things that add value to my to my
life will also change so I'm 35 now I
have a three year old and so my life
looks different now and say when I was
28 when I first embraced them in a
Muslim and so just because I brings
something into my life like a jacket
doesn't mean I'm always going to fall
into it because I'm no longer getting
value from it I have to be willing to
let go I have to walk away from it so I
can fill my life with things to do my
body well would be step one for somebody
who's listening to this right now who
finds what you're talking about
appealing like where can they start I
think it starts with a question really
if that's yourself how might i life be
better with less I think my intern that
question we identify the the purpose of
minimalism and it's not just the the al2
side of things it's the more important
why two side of things and once we
identify that like how might your life
leave over the last for me it was
starting with finances because I made
really good money in the corporate world
but spent even better money
yeah and that equation just doesn't work
so I'd massive amounts of debt at sixty
years worth of debt half a million
dollars became my more
and I was just drowning in it but I was
also unhealthy I weighed 80 pounds more
than I weigh now my relationships are in
shambles I wasn't creating what I wanted
to create I wasn't contributing to the
community around me and I found out that
if I got rid of the things that I was
focused on let's focus on the wrong
stuff though I could focus on the
benefits my health my passions my
creativity and only if I align today's
actions with those values that is Joshua
fields Milburn is here with Ryan
Nicodemus and they are the minimalist
everybody
[Applause]
all right Joshua and Ryan you teach
people how to make space in their lives
for the things that really matter but
the two of you don't always agree on
what is and isn't a keeper right when it
comes to physical stuff so we thought
that we would savagely pit you two
against each other to weigh in on some
real-life items from our lives as a
radio show staff so what we're going to
do is we're going to show you some
things that are real objects that we own
and then one of you is going to make the
argument for keeping it and one of you
is going to make the argument for
getting rid of it it's a little segment
we're calling should it stay or should
it go now
my wire house man
[Applause]
all right so I'm going to kick things
off and it was a slightly visual for the
radio but I will describe it to the
people out there listening to us are not
able to do what we're doing I hold in my
hand a very gaudy gold Reebok Pump
basketball shoe 1985 called they want
the shoes back alright alright alright
you haven't even learned if you're
supposed to be arguing for her again
I've tried this while you're all is this
your shoe this is my shoe I brought this
shoe from my house I have both of them
by the way but they're kind of clunky so
I only brought one with me to sister
illustrate the point now let me tell you
the story briefly behind my acquisition
of this Reebok Pump basketball shoe when
I was a kid and the Reebok Pump came out
it was like $200 which I think was about
50% of what my dad made per month so
there would be no Reebok pumping in the
Burbank household and then when I grew
up one time I went into Fred Segal in
Los Angeles about ten years ago and what
did I see a Reebok Pump basketball shoe
that I could afford I mean that's let's
be honest debatable if it was a good
financial decision but I was able to
acquire this thing that I had to wanted
as a child and it was admitted something
to me about what my adult life had come
to I guess or had added up to I also
mentioned I have never worn these shoes
outside of the house
they are ridiculous looking should it
stay or should it go now Joshua are you
for why it should go
I mean you are you've already made the
argument for why they should go right
I've never warned them it sounds to me
like you essentially did no value from
them well sometimes I look at him and I
realize I'm not as poor as I was when I
was a kid that value do you require a
sneaker to realize that you have clearly
not met me Josh Matt here's another
thing like if you were happy if you were
actually I can tell right now just by
talking to you you're not having any
trouble letting go this thing but if you
were having trouble letting go of it
what I would encourage you to do if you
did want to get rid of you said this is
not adding any value to my life it's
just getting in the way is taking up
space it's weighing on my mind first
getting rid of it's going to take that
weight off your shoulders
but jacket experience lasting
contentment just might get it rid of a
pair of Reeboks pose but if for some
reason it's a sentimental Island you're
like I still want to get rid of it you
can take a picture of it because the
memories that we have aren't in our
things
the memories are inside us but sometimes
the things we have can trigger those
memories so quite often before I get rid
of something I'll take a photo of it and
then I'll let it go all right Ryan you
have the past of explaining why I should
hang on to this pair of Reeboks
basketball shoes that I wear oh man if
you are someone who likes to take up a
space for no reason you are someone who
loves living in the past and can't live
in the present I don't feel like your
heart Simmons right absolutely keep them
in those pieces all right that's all
I'll keep it I'm working my way up to
where you guys are at okay we have the
minimalists here and next up we have our
producer and editor of our show Laura
Patton's coming on stage all right Laura
maybe guess what it is
how about how about we describe what
it's sort of physical appearances for
the radio listeners it looks a little
bit like a like a diaper pail maybe that
would be in a in a bathroom or something
it's about three feet high it's a
cylinder with an electric trash can it
is Laura Hatton what is this thing
you've brought on stage anyone ask the
minimal it's about it's a towel warmer
soon towel warmer I feel like it's kind
of in the name but we explain how it
works yeah so before I get to the shower
I put my towel in it and I press a
button and it warms it while I'm in the
shower
so that when I get out of the shower
it's at the perfect temperature
this sounds like it adds value to your
life because it warms you and you get a
shower
how many times have you bought this
particular item I received one as a
present and I thought it was ridiculous
and then it broke and then I bought
another one
this would be your second for some foul
water that you have owned in your life
okay
so now we turn to the minimalists one of
you has to make carrier for why this
thing should stay and one why it should
go Ryan would you like to make the
argument as to why this should go um
once the last time you use it this
morning
oh um does this stress you out at all
now when it broke a distressed
um I don't you know I might get rid of
that just because it's an electrical
device like close to the bathtub and
stuff maybe so you might want to
consider getting rid of it for that
reason
safety safety safety first okay Joshua
what what argument could be made for for
keeping a Brookstone brand towel warmer
I mean it's awesome
[Music]
I mean here's the thing have you ever
had a warm cow and you got out of the
shower if I know okay I spend all my
money on Reebok pumps understand where
you jump out into a shower but never
yeah here's what I'll say if you use
that every day and you get a Vince value
promise you shouldn't get rid of it I
don't know why you would even freak why
you would even question that and with
anything in my life actually that's not
true I encourage your question it's good
because now you're making the deliberate
decision to hold on to that and you're
going to get more value from it because
you know you're using it intentionally
all right I'm telling argument from
Bashan I have the sense and Laura's
going to hold on to that bad boy
all right and last but not least we have
our announcer Jason rouse who has an
item that he's been holding on to for a
long time I don't even know where to
begin trying to describe the fresh
health and environment stage at the
Avera Rose Theater the Jason will you
please describe this very upsetting
puppet introduce it to the little Tony
Sinclair and he is a puppet of a very
close old friend of mine named Tony
Sinclair live in Chicago and he was made
by friend of mine last year for it for a
show I did and it you know it hasn't
really realistic imagined I'm just gonna
try describe this for folks listening on
the radio it's sort of like a
three-foot-tall Michael Myers from
Halloween
did you say that someone accurate
descriptions oh yeah then it's fall
Jason Todd this was made for a plane
that you were in and it is actually it's
a likeness of a friend of yours yeah
pretty close yeah he for the same outfit
in the show and and we the joke was that
he was cloned and this was the clone and
everyone thought that this was the real
Tony
I drove real Tony insane and so now I
have it in my apartment where where does
this ventriloquism doll live in your
apartment in a very unwieldy box that
has to be stored and you know taken care
of it's been suggested by my girlfriend
that he live just on a shelf overlooking
everything and I Wow I you know I've
gone ahead and vetoed that
yeah just trying to eat spaghetti well
this is watching that
that thing that seems like you would see
deeply upsetting anybody who came over
to roust manner yeah all right minimal
time to weigh in on Jason rouses Michael
Myers at 3 football the total ISM W
attention mitch is wearing a hoodie for
some reason and g's and some velcro
sneakers okay
Joshua fields Milburn what is the
argument for getting rid of this do you
want to keep it sort of I do
I was made by a good friend it's a
representation of a very close friend
who doesn't live here but you know it's
a weird puppet of my friend
I call my friend about this but II
wouldn't help him I tended his gaze away
from you either
oh just you talk or you get rid of me
don't even try yes actually you know
what that's a good point that's not the
kind of doll you throw out it's coming
back to you yeah if I've learned
anything from horror film yep there's an
entire chucky series predicated yeah
good actually I think I hear the only
other thing that I would say is it seems
to me that you're embarrassed to take it
out of its box at home or even to that
or terrified - well I mean I don't want
to just a man wanted to be safe you know
I mean and in the Box we save and he
look at that imagine wandering around
your house just casually and you know I
think the issue by the way this is one
of the times when I think God I which is
a TV show but I think it's just that
it's right in that sort of uncanny
valley James and if I might wait it's a
little too lifelike it would be better
if it was a little bit less real looking
okay so let's just let's just get this
thing off the stage by moving it to you
Ryan
what does the argument for keeping this
nightmare
look how adorable that hope it is
oh are you meant relative no yeah do you
have dreams of becoming advanced relic
West no oh well I think maybe you should
pick up being a ventriloquist and and
and use this in your act
um you know again if you love to take up
empty space yeah god I'm having trouble
having a hard time coming up I would
just go with Luke's argument of if you
throw that thing away it's probably to
come back and haunt you so don't do it
they say very good all right sage advice
from writing the PG Macintosh McMillan
older they are the minimal
[Applause]
a little singing you think that's me
every little thing you bring back me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bear that you were fine
without it
every little thing that you got a
headache
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach full bloom and you gotta
grab oh I bet you the Sun okay hey okay
[Music]
Oh